los enfrentamientos entre las dos
facciones armadas sudanesas
recrudecieron nuevamente actualizando la
crisis en el inestable país del sahel
que apuntaba a la conformación de un
gobierno democrático y civil en el
mediano plazo las diferencias radican en
el plan de reunificación del ejército
con los grupos armados irregulares por
un lado el ejército liderado por abdel
fatal actual presidente del Consejo
soberano sudanés por el otro el líder
del grupo paramilitar fuerzas de apoyo
rápido y vicepresidente de la cúpula
gobernante vigente Mohamed hamanda galo
alias emetti ambos alburgán y emetti
salieron en 2021 para derrocar al
gobierno civil de transición
el país sigue comprometido con el
contenido de la declaración
constitucional del periodo provisional
en 2019 y el acuerdo en suran del Sur
que se firmó en Cuba en octubre de 2020
los militares soportaron levantamientos
ciudadanos y críticas internacionales
por el golpe a la administración
designada la destitución del presidente
islamista Omar albair en abril de 2019
desde entonces alburham ratificó la
voluntad de entregar el poder a civiles
firmando el acuerdo marco en diciembre
pasado el cual definía los pasos a
seguir para terminar el proceso político
uno de los últimos asuntos a resolver
era el nuevo rol del ejército con el fin
de alejarlo de la vida política nacional
y de las actividades económicas Dios
queremos acabar con el uso de las
fuerzas armadas Para apoyar partidos
políticos o para imponer dictaduras y
apoyar gobiernos totalitarios queremos
construir fuerzas armadas que respeten
las normas de los regímenes democráticos
sin embargo el acuerdo entre alburham y
emetti no sucedió mtti ganó influencia
liderando las fuerzas de apoyo un bloque
que se desprendió de las milicia
shanghawick que perpetró masacres entre
2003 y 2008 en tanto que se hizo con
grandes cantidades de oro convirtiéndose
en el hombre más rico del país su
objetivo era la reunificación y que se
ejecutó una modernización en las
instituciones militares motivo que
retrasó la firma final del pacto por
segunda vez la cual estaba estipulado
por el pasado 1 de abril y que no
permite Cesar la violencia en el país